Phật xí đúng chưa phát sạch?
Nó bước chảy,
dùng người kịp dài kíu tại sế bị mắt kẹp.
Bước xảy ra sáng mề lắm tháng mời trên đường buổi thịt xuân
vào vệ khách sạch nhìn thấy thách xí trước sạch tòa nhà có hỏi lượng nên chạy tới kìm chả.
Phát hiện tại sế bên trong,
người này chạy lấy bình chữa chảy,
cô hán dùng người đến giấc lượng.
Đi tần gần, bài xế,
có để góp ra được dịt dài chế,
dịt dẹp, có bởi kìa tả.
Mọi người mà có lý.
Tới điểm sạch ra trảy trong xè khu khách,
theo bình Việt đã qua lâm đồng,
nạn nhân năm 15 tuổi ở phương xun hương đà là,
đi bọng nặng,
được chuyển đi thành phố Hội Chí Minh Dự chi.
Cứ bò chức năng đã phong toả hiện trường để điều tra nguyên nhân.